pour vous il est arrivé quelque chose
aux petits levure à augmenter la
production et désirs du führer son
désordre l'héroïque bataille de
stalingrad et quelqu'un vous rétablir la
vérité
quand on lit tous ces mensonges autant
je suis occupé je crie à coups j'écris
des cartes
qui dit la vérité
je fais ta compagne est immonde
empêchera pas
ombre d'hitler s'étend sur l'europe
comme l'ombre du diable
c'est l'oeuvre d'un parc utting mai sur
abc il sortait combien 127
c'est comme avec une machine peu de
sable dans les rouages d'une seule
empêche pas tournée
dans ma tête j'ai beaucoup de personnes
qui jettent des grains dans les rouages
diddy noah qui est l'auteur de ces
cartes
parce qu on me posera la question et que
je devrais répondre tu as exactement
deux jours
partir d'aujourd'hui on est seul comment
tu fais pour garder ton calme
on a dit qu'on faisait ça à deux on va
pas arrêter
on attend on attend que notre ami face
au faux pas
tout le monde est important